[Music]
and China coming under intense scrutiny
this week amid mounting criticism of its
early response to the corona virus
outbreak my first guest this morning was
one of the first to see the pandemic
coming we want to bring in White House
trade adviser Peter Navarro Peter it's
great to see this morning and thank you
for all of your early warnings and your
great work on this Peter I know you've
been busy with the supply chain issues
but I want to talk first about China and
what we're learning this morning
pro-democracy activists were arrested
over the weekend Peter a further
crackdown on Hong Kong as China
continues to exert authoritarianism
throughout Hong Kong your reaction to
what we saw this weekend and broadly
speaking what China has done in the
midst of this current virus pandemic
Maria my focus here at the White House
is making sure the people of America are
safe from this virus in getting things
like personal protective equipment masks
ventilators and things like that but
here's what I can tell you about China
if you think about what China did over
the course of this thing they did four
things that led to the deaths of many
people worldwide I mean first of all the
virus was spawned in China second of all
they hid the virus behind the shield of
the World Health Organization the third
thing they did was basically hoard
personal protective equipment and now
they're profiteering from it and if you
walk through that you were one of the
first in the media to raise the question
of whether that p4 lab was involved
that's an it's an interesting issue what
we know is that the ground zero for this
virus was within a few miles of that lab
if you simply do an Occam's razor
approach that the simplest explanation
is probably the most likely I think it's
incumbent on China to prove that it
wasn't that lab so that's number one but
more importantly we know that for a
critical six week period of time China
used its influence at the World Health
Organization the high
the virus from the world this was a time
where that virus could have been
contained in Wuhan instead five million
Chinese people went out from Wuhan and
propagated the virus around the world
that was a critical time so so that was
that and then here's what I think should
be very disturbing to every American
during that period of time that's six
week interval when they were hiding this
virus from the world China went from a
net exporter of personal protective
equipment they are the largest producer
of that in the world to a large net
import and they basically went around
and vacuumed up virtually all of the PPE
around the world including a lot from
this country which was for humanitarian
reasons sharing our PPE with them and
what that did was leave people in New
York Milan and everywhere in between
defenseless when it came time to you
have that PPE now what's happening today
which which is equally alarming is China
is sitting on that hoard of PPE where it
cornered the market and it's
profiteering I have cases that are
coming across my desk where 50 cent
masks made in China or being sold the
hospitals here in America or as much as
$8 this is a situation a month ago when
I got a call from a leading hospital
executive who said to me Maria
there are masks and gloves protective
equipment that were on a ship coming
from China to America those ships were
told to turn around that China said
we're not keeping any commitments that
we had to export any of this stuff China
wants it and then as you point out they
cornered the market they already produce
half of the world's capacity of this
protective gear and yet they were in the
market buying two billion additional
masks in January Peter I don't
understand what's going on here I mean
this is even more sinister than we
thought
first the this virus escapes sick
the world and then they turn around and
try to make it harder for the United
States to get the products they need I
think that China right now after doing
those four actions which which
effectively have killed to date 39,000
Americans a hundred and sixty thousand
people worldwide may attempt to use this
crisis now to advance their own agenda
worldwide so yeah my focus right now is
just make sure people have everything
they need here but I think there's a
attention to that you're working with
Honeywell you're working with a number
of companies you're doing a lot even in
New York with Mayor DeBlasio we're gonna
get to that I want to make sure the
audience understands what's happening
but let me get your take on this if we
see all of this bad behavior continuing
from China or our global company is
going to recognize if they want to sell
to one point four billion people in
China they need to do so with their eyes
open you've got intellectual theft
continuing you've got a million wee
girls right now in camps in China
you've got tracking of citizens you've
got all of this behavior going on in in
China so I spoke with Secretary of State
Mike Pompeo on Friday and I asked the
secretary is the world getting it is is
European is Europe for example our
friends in Europe saying to the
secretary
look maybe we will unwind that hot
huawei technology take a listen to what
the secretary said in regards to
European friends and global businesses
and whether or not there's a new
thinking around China here's what the
secretary told me Friday I am very
confident that at this moment this
moment where the Chinese Communist Party
failed to be transparent and open and
handled data in an appropriate way
will cause many many countries to
rethink what they were doing with
respect to their telecom architecture
and when Huawei comes knocking to sell
them equipment and hardware that they
will have a different prism through
which to view that decision I'm I'm
hopeful that's the case this is about
security and making sure that US data
Americans data that travels across their
networks is safe and secure
as well what will happen to companies
that are aligned with China two things I
think this has been a real moment for
business leaders all across America to
see the political risk associated with
operations inside of China
you know this where you've been around a
lot of these people they can deal with
commercial risk they can deal with all
kinds of political risk is enormous ly
difficult to deal with it now we've
ripped the band-aid off the political
risk connected to that second the United
States government has a responsibility
to we need to make sure the supply chain
for the products that matter for
American national security and keeping
people safe are no longer dependent on
any single country and we have a
responsibility to get that right so so
with Peter Navarro this morning Peter
you're the point man on the supply chain
we're gonna take a break when we come
back from the break I'm gonna tell ask
you what you're doing right now but
broadly speaking before we go to break
real quick do you see a different shift
in thinking from companies trying to
move the supply chain back to the United
States as a result of China's behavior I
see since President Donald J Trump took
office the only president who's ever
stood up to China since he took office
we've seen a shift of that supply chain
because of the kinds of risk that
secretary Pompeo so eloquently just
stated yeah I think this election is
going to be about China